i'm always on the lookout for ways to
make myself better to make my business
better and recently when i was on my
cruise ship i found an exercise ball
you can see one here and i found when i
sat on it my posture was a lot better
you have to really sit on these things
straight or or you fall off and i don't
like sitting down
in general as a rule i use a stand-up
desk i like standing up because it's
better for your back better for my knees
but sometimes i sit down at my boardroom
table and i used to use a chair and i'll
show you what happens so
i run mastermind meetings this group of
entrepreneurs who get together once a
month and that's usually when i sit down
in my chair and i found like as the
meeting goes on i'm leaning like this or
i'm slouching over
and i end up hurting my back because
this is a big slouch to it or i'm like
this and relaxing and again it's not
it's not great for you and it doesn't
look great either so what i'm trying now
is using an exercise box so i just
bought this thing
and tested out for my meetings
and if i bring it in
see as i sit down on it
it forces you
let's do this angle to have a straight
back see how i'm moving still so my
lower body is still it's still a little
bit engaged and i can still sit at the
height of the table
um but if i try to lean if i try to do
this i should just crack my back
uh i'm gonna fall
so it forces you to have good posture
and to keep your
body moving a little bit so a lot better
for you than your traditional chair so
i'm gonna test this out and use it for
the means that i have in here the other
thing i found was when i bought this
the thing moves around so when you're
not sitting on it it kind of moves
around and i didn't i didn't want uh
this ball moving around my office so i
wanted to find the stand and these
stands can be pricey but i didn't want
something
to ghetto what i ended up doing was i
actually so this is my stand here
and it just stays here but all i did to
make this look nice was i went to
walmart
and i got
a dog dish
i just got one of these
dog dishes that you have for
big dogs
i don't know 10 bucks
and i use that as my stand
so i can put that there
and it stays in place so that's my
lifestyle tip of the day
if you guys find it interesting you want
to see more of these kinds of things
that i'm into let me know i'll make a
video response if you guys like the
video thumbs up below if you have
questions leave it in the comments thank
you guys i'll see you soon